demand for rapid innovation often keeps
enterprises in most industries near the
edge of chaos while Enterprise IT once
operated in the background it now drives
business value by creating new
compelling user experiences delivered on
cloud platforms delivering modern
applications requires a cloud native
approach to application development
combined with DevOps tools and practices
cloud native development lets you
continuously deliver updates customers
want the IBM cloud apps service
kick-starts cloud native development by
making it simple to build and deploy new
micro services based apps and by
providing teams the tools languages
frameworks and security needed to
practice polyglot application
development at high velocity cloud
native development lets you organize
teams and tasks around business needs
and deliver new applications as a set of
micro services easily access higher
level services like AI blockchain and
IOT to delight customers because IBM
cloud services harness expertise and
worldwide infrastructure your team is
free to focus on what your customers
need try the IBM cloud apps service
today to get started building your cloud
native application
[Music]
[Applause]